يقومون يدويًا بدفن
جثة فتاة صغيرة مكفنة باللون الأبيض في أرض
مستشفى ناصر في كانيونس،
الرمال الناعمة في المستشفى هي أحد
الأماكن الآمنة الوحيدة لدفن
الموتى، وهي الآن محور
الهجوم الإسرائيلي في غزة.  حيث تعتقد إسرائيل أن
بعض الرهائن وكذلك
بعض قادة حماس موجودون، ولكن
بعد أسابيع من العمليات المكثفة، لم
يجدوا أن
الحرب لم تدخل شهرها الرابع،
ويحذر القادة الإسرائيليون من أنها قد
تستمر حتى نهاية العام مع احتمال
توقف مبكر.  بالنسبة للقتال الذي تجاهله
البيت الأبيض، فإنك لا تعتقد أن
وقف إطلاق النار سيكون في
صالح أي أحد، لكن
حماس قد يعترض البعض في غزة على ذلك. فقد
انسحبت القوات الإسرائيلية
في الوقت الحالي من أجزاء من وسط غزة في
منطقة اللاجئين  يبحث سكان المخيم عن
ما تبقى من حياتهم المحطمة أو
ربما مجرد بقايا من
الحطب، وقد لجأ مئات الآلاف
إلى مدارس الأمم المتحدة المكتظة الآن.
وحذر مسؤولو الأمم المتحدة من أن نقص
الصرف الصحي والمياه النظيفة والأدوية
والمأوى المناسب يؤدي إلى انتشار
المرض، فرت أم محمد إلى هنا.  مع
عائلتها فقط لم يجدوا
مساحة [موسيقى] للمخيم في مدرسة أخرى تابعة للأمم المتحدة،
الكتب المدرسية تبقي النار مشتعلة لطهي
وجبة، لقد كان كابوسًا هنا بينما كان
القتال محتدمًا بالقرب من الكابوس الذي
بالنسبة للبعض ليس
فوق
جسد والده  والبعض الآخر يقع على
رمال غزة الناعمة خلف المدرسة ولا يوجد شاهد
قبر فقط أسماء مرسومة على
الحائط بن ويدمان تقرير سي إن إن من
بيروت